- Today we're gonna talk about the biggest
time wasters in law school
and how to avoid them for better grades.
So stick around and get
an edge in law school.
(light piano notes)
Okay, time waster number one.
This is the one that most students lose
the most amount of time on.
And those are case briefs.
These things are huge wastes of time.
These are the multi colored bastards
that will suck up all of your time
in your first semester in law school.
You're summarizing all of the cases
that your law professors provides to you.
All because you might've seen it on TV
or on Legally Blonde.
These are the biggest wastes of time.
We have a whole video devoted to why
case briefs are a bad idea.
But the bottom line is that you just can't
use the information
that you're summarizing
out of your law school
cases on your final exam.
Don't waste your time on case briefs,
there are better ways
of reading your cases.
You can do it faster, you
can do it more efficiently,
in fact, we have an entire e-book devoted
specifically to how to read your cases.
We give it away for free.
You can get the link below.
Time waster number two,
preparing for in class cold calling.
Law school is known for
the Socratic method.
In other words, cold calling on students
to describe their cases or
to explain different nuances
of different legal situations.
For many people, this is terrifying.
But, as terrifying as it is,
it's also completely useless.
There is almost a 0%
chance that you're going
to use what another
student has said in class
on your final.
You should prepare for class in the sense
that you want to try and get a handle
on the law that's going to be discussed.
But it's just not worth
the diminishing returns
of preparing for the off
chance that you might get
cold called in class.
Time waster number three,
trying to impress your professor.
Unlike college,
participation rarely counts
for anything in law school.
So don't go into class trying
to impress your professor.
Don't go into office hours thinking that
by discussing the cases
with your professor
you're going to impress them
and be able to talk up your grade.
It's just not gonna happen.
If you do go into office hours,
do it for yourself.
Try to understand
something that you weren't
able to understand before.
But don't go into office hours thinking
that you're going to impress the professor
and therefore get a better grade.
Be wary of showing off in class.
It's hard to listen when you're talking.
Steven Covey said, "Most
people do not listen
"with the intent to understand;
"they listen with the intent to reply."
And I see that in law school all the time.
If your mouth is open,
your ears are closed.
So don't try to impress your professor.
By the same token, another time waster
is trying to impress your friends.
A general rule in law
school, don't be a douche.
And don't be a gunner.
Gunners tend to do poorly in class.
And that's because when you're talking,
you're not listening.
So it's better to listen in class.
Don't try to impress your friends,
don't try to impress
them in a study group,
just listen, you'll be better off for it.
And that brings me to
time waster number five.
Which is trying to memorize
the detail of cases.
Other than just the rule or the facts.
We can spend an infinite amount of time
trying to memorize every
single nuance of the case.
But for the most part,
your professor is going to
explain the most important
parts of that case.
There's no point in
trying to memorize every
single detail outside of
what your professor provides.
So listen when your professor is talking
about the cases.
And certainly pay attention
to the facts of the case,
and the bright line
rule if the case happens
to provide that.
But other than that,
similar to case briefing,
it's not worth your time
in trying to memorize every
single portion of the cases
you discuss or the history of the law
or other legals aspects that you'll
find in commercial outlines.
Which brings me to time waster number six.
Which is, looking for the right answer.
In law school, you have
to be okay with ambiguity.
Everything is one big gray area.
In fact, in real life,
the cases that go to trial
are the ones that could go either way.
If a case is an easy one,
then it will settle beforehand.
And in law school you're going to be faced
with ambiguous situation
after ambiguous situation.
You have to come to grips with the idea
that there may not be a right answer.
You may have to go with
the least bad answer.
Or you may have to deal with
differing shades of gray.
Either way, you can't waste your time
by trying to find the right answer.
Metaphysics has no place in law school.
Be comfortable with uncertainty
and it will be your friend
and you'll actually be able
to use it to great effect
in law school exams.
So if you can avoid
those six time wasters,
you're gonna be off to a great start,
and you're gonna have an
edge on everybody else.
Oh and by the way,
if you want to get better
grades on your next
law school final check this out,
we've put together a free e-book
called the Ultimate Guide to
Crushing Law School Finals.
Just click the link below to download it.
It'll show you exactly how to prepare
for your next final,
including how to plan,
how to outline, and how to
study for your next final.
Just click below.
Also, if you liked this video,
please subscribe to our channel,
we come out with new videos
on how to crush law school all the time.
So thanks from everyone
here at Legal Eagle.
(funky music)